yeah made me wizard book here he's scary
Joanna's okay I'm an Jones the ABCs
nature nerd and today we've got viral
videos of goannas
[Music]
oh and just quickly if you like this
sort of video why don't you hit the
subscribe button for more let's get
cracking knees Nick turning sideways
standing up to make himself look much
bigger more likely to come over me leg
off he's aggressive that is entirely
aggressive stance saying stay away from
me
see that up on hind legs wow it took all
of the weight off his front legs seized
every muscle is resting
there are a number of things that are go
in and will do in defense of its own
personal safety they've got some decent
chompers in there they think they've got
their very own venom it's not used for
killing things but rather for digesting
them which is sort of disgusting they've
got claws that are insane and pretty
scary and on top of that that really
must sleet ale they can use that to like
smash things that they want to it's all
muscle they've got actually pretty good
control of it that's brave waitress see
how strong he is as well so what's
happening is mm-hmm
to protect the patrons of the lovely
establishment that waitress has grabbed
the tail of a very large goanna
and what you can see is that she's
trying to drag him away and he's
actually affecting her movements that's
how strong he is he's both his grip on
the ground and also the muscle movement
you know because they can sort of move
all the way through to those tails are
really muscly so yeah good effort on her
part but good effort on that go and his
part as well but really I probably would
have moved the humans rather than move
the goanna because it probably would
have moved through Johanna is like this
catch-all term for a big group of lizard
type things in Australia and there's
some Roy big ones that live out in the
desert that are called paren t's but
then there are goanna Zoar monitor
lizards that are really tiny like tiny
little miniature dragons that you might
see in a cartoon that are absolutely
gorgeous and these guys are both
fearsome predators and smelly scavengers
[Laughter]
they're incredible at being a garbage
got some bloody eating anything
wrap the salmon what see the seagull
looking of that as well like just leave
it jettison the food no no the salami is
stopped at the last straw
going up rickety oh he's getting up the
tree because they've got great claws
they can climb almost any after ranger
picnics and wildlife don't mix don't
feed wildlife it leads to this sort of
situation kaki is agitated kaki has
crest up and is complaining birds are
like the best giveaways for when
predators are around oh I see that
forked tongue and they use it like snake
uses its tongue so it's using it as a
sensor and it's bringing sent back up to
a special thing that's on the top of its
mouth so that it can smell everything
that's in the area so the kaki is it's a
defensive thing is telling everyone that
this lizard is here they essentially
annoy them until they go somewhere else
this is a tried-and-true method from a
cocky
there have been freak incidents right
where people are bitten by Parenti zorga
honours or monitor visits it happens
they're wild animals but in terms of how
deadly I think the answer is probably
not very deadly however a bit of advice
don't start feeding them if you start
feeding them they'll become habituated
to you and then you're gonna have a mini
Godzilla coming to visit you so you
don't want to do that what animal should
we do next if you've got a suggestion
leave it in the comments below and make
sure you subscribe to ABC science and
until next time see you later